okay hi thank you guys so much for being
patient with us we appreciate it
um I am Sarah hi Pola and I am a
freelance writer in New York but I used
to live in Austin and I worked at the
Austin Chronicle and I'm glad to be back
here as always but I am here today as a
fan um this is the onion panel and it's
taking place in a church which is really
weird but also somehow appropriate
fitting I want to introduce you to Dan
and Mike who will be doing most of the
heavy lifting this afternoon
they are head writers on the book are
dumb world and they're going to be
giving us presentations and then at the
end you guys are going to have questions
if you have any and then they're going
to sign copies of this wonderful book
which is hilarious and rather
astonishingly detailed and much much
better than the terrible gift books most
people give each other around Christmas
because it is finely detailed and also
hilarious it is the Faberge egg of fake
textbooks so for a moment let's talk
about the onion here's what I know about
the onion they have terrible fact
checkers also I've been a journalist for
10 years now and I have subscriptions to
12 magazines and yet picking up the
onion each week is really the one pure
and entirely joyful media experience I
have their stories are entertaining and
sometimes they hurt me they're so funny
and they are deceptively informative
when I read a book like our dumb world
it makes me feel smarter for being in on
the joke I would submit that our dumb
world actually taught me more about our
dumb world than actual atlases but you
can decide for yourselves as Dan and
Mike offer us a multimedia presentation
which in a sudden hitch is going to be
done by me over there so we'll just try
to get through it we're very lucky to
have them here please help me welcome
[Applause]
good afternoon I'm Dan butterman I'm
Mike Senzu we are the head writers of
our dumb world The Onion's atlas to the
planet Earth a book Newsweek has called
the best humor parody in 30 years and
our fathers have called not bad today
we'll be taking you around the world the
countries many of you may never heard of
before countries like Vanuatu Mauritania
France but first we begin with the
United States - that's our visual cue
and one more one more
hey so how many of you are from the
United States now how many of you are in
the United States right now ah 39 but a
few so as you know the the United States
is the land of opportunity and click and
you can click off of that now it is the
home of the American Dream the American
dream it is a place where money walks
talks hits on a woman half your age talk
some more purchases a toaster to try and
fill the void you feel inside
embarrasses you in front of some old
friends and finally laughter you laugh
say you with glee as you sit in your
empty studio apartment and stare at that
photo of your ex-wife America stretches
from coast to coast from the Northeast
click places like Vermont clean air
filthy people
to New Jersey demanding people shove it
up their ass since 1892 to the south
including Arkansas we're second cousins
our first wives and Tennessee like hija
but a state and let's not forget about
Florida home of the silent Holocaust
each year it it seems of course it seems
at first glance like a tropical paradise
but inside these lurks the dark secret
each year thousands of Jews are sent
there to die
I lost both my grandparents to Florida
now it's a the u.s. also stretches from
the West including Nevada where everyone
is a loser
to Texas which in 2004 changed its
national model from don't mess with
Texas to to you you just mess with Texas
didn't you didn't you - and 2007 you see
you see what happens when you mess with
Texas do you see
of course there's also the Midwest
America's pitstop
and finally our nation's [ __ ] states
Alaska Hawaii and Minnesota land of
10,000 retards of course America is not
the only country in the world just the
most important to the north lies Canada
one more target again make it happen and
the click
yeah the people of Canada can be divided
into two groups those who are polite and
those who are too polite to bring up the
fact that they've been placed in the
wrong group the National score in Canada
is ice hockey
although ice fishing also enjoys great
popularity as does ice volleyball ice
auto racing and field hockey which is
played on ice now let's click one more
time and take a look at a typical
Canadian summer home beautiful annual
temperatures in Canada range from
coldest [ __ ] to coldest [ __ ] to too cold
to swear now let's why don't we take a
trip down to some warmer climates and
take a look at our neighbor to the south
Mexico and click to the slogan one more
clicking now hiring 2.4 million bucks
boys as many of you know Mexico is
suffering from a bit of an unskilled
labor shortage as millions cross the
border each year come to the US looking
for jobs as dishwashers and lawnmowers
leaving the nations brilliant scientists
and physicists helpless as there's no
janitors in the entire country to unlock
the door to their building
Mexico also has a long varied history
reaching back thousands of years here we
see the work of ancient Mayans and next
to it the work of modern minds we
totally agree with this moving on to
Central America Panama a shortcut with
its own national anthem so the right
there you'll see a Panama Canal which is
one of the one of mankind's greatest
achievements and digging and now let's
take a look at a well you could click
through pest yeah there we go
Puerto Rico in a parade right now you
could click the thing and then again
take a look at a the morning commute
in Puerto Rico if you click one more
time off to work at the flag Factory
I bet if you'll click again let's now
look at South America the second-best
America and starless Brazil you know
click to see the slogan they're people
of their most beautiful humanity at its
ugliest you know Brazil is home to some
of the most beautiful shapely just
voluptuous most sexy victims of violent
assault and murder in the world
Brazilian women you know they have these
large incredibly expressive eyes that
just seem to almost say help on being
raped Hey rest of you can yeah
but why don't we take a look at some of
the landmarks around bazzill
with
remember you are in a church right the
Christ the Avengers that you looming
above the attention and if you'll click
past
next we'll see the breathtaking Amazon
rainforest just beautiful exciting click
through and click one more time
as far as natural beauty goes however
Brazilian people can't be beat man
never has limited access to safe
drinking water looked this good there's
women love their buckets they sure do
ok let's uh let's click on over to
Argentina which is the only other
country in South America as far as
you're concerned and if you'll click
again you'll see some beautiful Nazi
retirement community yes SS officers
retired there for years where they can
just sit back and reminisce about the
good old days flip through old Holocaust
scrapbook tell those long rambling
stories about the best way to cremate a
Jew there are very cheap will quickly
move off the stage now
who and let's mods please unfortunately
the world is not as cheery and carefree
as North and South America there is of
course Africa when Micah and I first
began researching Africa we were both in
our early 20s Mike is now 76 and I've
been dead for four years in Africa
you'll learn about click through and
click again Malawi come for the food
shortages stay because you've died and
you'll click again
Kenya running 26.2 miles from their
problems which sometimes is not far
enough and then of course click there's
the nation of Djibouti
congratulations you just laughed at
thousands of starving people
before we continue though we'd like to
ask if there are any small children in
the audience that they'd be escorted out
seniors and those with heart conditions
should leave as well as well as anyone
who's not completely numb to the pain
and anguish of the human condition as we
click forward and take a look at some of
the grisly sights of Africa we'll do it
very quickly because some of these are
ever your eyes very painful let's click
and see the first one alright get that
off the screen arable I let's see the
next one
awful let's get out of there and then
the last one
there is no God however we did learn
about some nations we might never heard
of before if you'll click through and
see the nation of Namibia we vacinated
like culturally diverse nation with a
lot to offer you know here's some of the
stunning natural beauty of Namibia if
you'll click past that you'll see the
some of the chief agricultural product
beautiful and of course Namibia's chief
mode of transportation there it is as
you all know Brad Pitt and Angelina
Jolie had their child in Namibia a
couple years ago they actually raised
the nation's gross domestic product by
5,000% when they tipped their waiter but
let's get a get out of that pecan go to
a delightful place the middle east will
click through big enough look at Iraq
they had it coming it had it coming
ladies and gentlemen you know in 2003 we
invaded Iraq which was not without just
caused as they in 1990 they gassed us
certain Kurdish villages in 2001 they
flew two planes into the World Trade
Center towers I believe they sunk the
Titanic they did they they were the ones
behind the Hindenburg explosion thanks
right and if I'm not mistaken they got
the Holocaust off the ground they did in
fact Saddam Hussein actually personally
assassinated John F Kennedy in 1963 and
he was also the man behind the paper cut
I received last week
and that was a terrible paper cut
although when I was 10 years old my bike
was stolen and it was behind that mic
that was a rack is my lot so but a wreck
is a culturally diverse place we'll take
a look at the ethnic breakdown of course
3/4 of Iraq is made up of Arab descent
you've got some Kurds in there and some
Tennesseans and Kentuckians also making
up quite a very very diverse lambskins
well enough about a reckless let's hop
on over to its neighbor Iran should be
coming up any second now there we go
quickly Iran a possible likely threat to
the free world
maybe with evidence pointing
conclusively to Iran either possessing
or not possessing nuclear weapons this
Middle Eastern nation could potentially
be poised to possibly launch a
full-scale attack on the free world
perhaps perhaps let's take a look at
this
Iran's a power plant
the only power plant to derive all its
energy from burning US flag what a bit
of energy - I put the power to the whole
city that's ours little country as well
let's take a look at some other
landmarks which I here's the monument to
their not being a Holocaust and of
course Iran flag the green and red
stripes of course represent Iran deep
abiding love of Christmas it's very
beautiful this time of year
everyone now fasten to the spared and
Christmas trees everywhere just yeah and
let's take a look at Israel now the
empty Promised Land
you know it was a it was promised to the
Jews actually by both God and the United
Nations however not many people believed
in either of these entities ability to
affect change in the world and next we
see a the Jews who control the world lay
two dozen there they are there they are
up to no good and Allen's on the cleanup
Palestine always exclusive Palestine and
you'll feel click through there are on
24-hour suicide bombing watch and now to
the right we can see an Israeli attack
helicopter enforcing curfew that's a
high let's get out a good on the mouth
and go to Europe I feel quick through
we'll start on the United Kingdom and
the ingress surging ahead to the
nineteenth in checking big leaps in the
last three centuries the British people
are known for their extremely British
sense of humor they'll laugh at anything
said in a dry serious tone of voice
which explains the success of their
highest-rated sitcom BBC World News
we tried to adapt that a couple years
ago over in the US it does not work out
oh well let's take a look at them
landmarks
there's gold henge
yes you are seeing snowman it's the
still and mystery who exactly Photoshop
that and why what was the purpose behind
this but I think we could all agree it
is quite a silly picture get that out
ruin and we'll take a look at the new
knights of the round table we gone are
the days of Sir Arthur but we they've
got Sir Paul and Sir Elton Sir bono sir
sting
not-not-not pictured as Sir Frampton and
Sir bad company and what's the hop on
over to Ireland and check out their glow
in the FATA go on whiskey is 2004 the
Irish people actually found that
legendary pot of gold which they then
promptly vomited it and here let's take
a look at some enterprising Irish use
yeah yeah those children are very happy
or were drunk or drunk especially that
kid on the end there they will not
remember this tomorrow
let's let's go over to our friends yes
and click through one nation above God
home to the Earth's entire population of
60 2.7 million people every single one
of the planets 427 cities and all of its
history culture and beauty France is the
only country in the world it's true
Frances the sole beacon of life and
civilization in an otherwise dark and
empty void France is the birthplace of
art aviation democracy reggae Buddhism
we the American Revolution happen right
John Wayne as well you know the Nile
River everything that ever happened has
happened in French arrogance as well yes
let's take a look at the rare sight of a
Frenchman weeping that's during the
great 1941 bre shortage the tragic time
in French history next up
Napoleon climb ah little-known fact he
was no bigger than the size of a thimble
he also had an interesting military
technique yes he would ride around in
the front shirt pocket of his first
lieutenant and climbed down the throat
of his enemies and eat their internal
organs brilliant unfortunate like all
military leaders Napoleon met his demise
he was caught in a butterfly net and
later drowned in the mound of mashed
potatoes
it's all true let's uh let's look at the
rights we come back let's go forward and
no no near the second time don't you
agree
here's the Frances flag the outer
two-thirds can be detached in case of
emergency surrendering
yeah yeah let's let France have it yep
happens more often than you'd think
they're over to Italy now there we are
Italy has a proud and amazing history
bring us the first Dominican look at
some of the Ancients s ancient
architecture earliest known Olive Garden
dating back to 600 BC the first known
evidence of fast and friendly service as
well as everlasting breadsticks yes
they're elastic breadstick let's when we
take a trip over to Venice the city of
romance
singing romantic gondola ride one lucky
gondolier we can go forward now to Spain
currently enjoying a three century
Fiesta yeah
pain is actually the only country in the
world that enjoys a seven-day weekend
aside from its laid-back ways Spain is
also home to find Susan like the Paia a
fried dish consisting of rice shrimp
pork lobster star Dean's Cornish hens
more pork paper towels rope I believe
wristwatches yeah basically anything
within arm's reach through it on a hot
day why don't we check out the next
photo which is a married couple running
away from a bull yes that's exactly
right you see they have both in Spain
and people also undeniably get married
there we put them together in a humorous
context Brenda please enjoy but we can
march on and take a look at vacant city
the Catholic Disneyland
family posing in front of st. Peter's
Magic Castle with one of the delightful
mascot
they've had there yep let's let's check
out some poke throughout the ages
starting with innocence the tenth and
then you get reptilian before season
right - perhaps - both frightening let's
let's keep it going here and check out
Russia and you can click the slogan is
okay we're Russians are sent to die now
let's look at one of the few livable
spots in all of Russia please click
ahead on the few livable spots now
Russia there it is relatively cozy and
then let's check out a cosmonaut coming
back from a successful successful space
voyage and if you'll continue on a
propaganda poster from the 1960s workers
stand in the bread line long red lines
there and now it's so let's talk about
Asia a little bit and beginning with
China a human assembly line it's a
actually the world's largest mass
producer of Chinese people
the right we actually see some 2006 2007
model Chinese unfortunately some of
those children would later be recalled
but there they are for now and this we
go on a doctor is also very popular
among American couples in China
yeah yeah that's right
a lot of a lot of married couples will
go to China to adopt babies yes a
relatively inexpensive although quite
difficult procedure you only have about
30 seconds and that large metal cloth
sometimes does it doesn't get a good
enough grip on the other children so
it's not as easy as it looks
also they always put the good children
in the corners so
okay we see a Chinese entrepreneur there
and as we go on China is known for its
exotic wildlife such as the giant panda
and its unique cuisine like the panda lo
mein okay
you can click past China oh you devious
as you could put up the slogan there
fling it hold while we die of malaria
India is a center for tech support as
you know and also the birthplace of
Hinduism so as you see here the Hindu
god of tech-support
taken some prayers that's step photo
taken at three o'clock in the morning in
the very patient God but sometimes hard
to understand and let's look at the
caste system so sorry the bottom would
be Untouchables and then up the social
ladder from the Warriors and the priests
and finally the cows at the top so a
secret animal in India and now you know
unlike doctors and scientists and
educators enjoy free reign to defecate
ultimately wherever they go it's
considered actually if a cow empties one
its bowels in your house it's considered
an honor but if the empties is vows in
your toilet it's considered a blessing
okay let's can't have it in the center
and let's now let's talk briefly about
eastern Asia it's a it's a place not
many people know about that it's
actually a lush and diverse land unique
in this each country its own and let's
take a look at the first one we've got a
Turkmenistan and now let's hop on over
to the cheek it's to him
let's not forget about is Becca Stan the
remarkable classic who's Becca Stan
photo and if we go to Kazakhstan there I
don't know what's that here's our
battery low running low you will also
find this in the app I guess kliklak
okay it's like okay okay
hahaha and select that you could play
play button upper left there you're
getting there it's let's get over yeah
[Applause]
yeah should be Bigfoot so yeah so that's
our presentation
astly
you owe me thank you
[Applause]
you only missed two countries and
they're both in the book so now I think
we're going to do some questions from
the audience so um see does anybody have
some questions right now okay sir you
and then also if you just want to line
up at the microphones after this
gentleman in the blue shirt talks that
would be great we'll have about what it
is for about 50 minutes deal with global
warming global warming oh we just don't
dress very warm we just pose less layer
that's why I do it no jacket it feels
like there was a global warming
conference that we mentioned in the book
which millions of Americans drove across
the nation to attend economic sanctions
you think should be levied against
mahmud I need a dinner jacket I mean
Almudena job for developing the berkeley
cyclotron and the second question is
when you the pair if you look deeply
into Putin's eyes what do you see well
answer your first question what kind of
economic sanctions bad ones
definitely bad ones we don't want to
give him any good economic sanction so
I'm going to go with bad there and what
do we see when we look at this Putin's
eyes a little boy we don't we don't know
because usually he's behind us about to
garrote us with a piano chord so any
other questions I have a question which
is how companies nothing a bit of the
mic sir I will not take I will not take
questions from that mic how do you put
this put together like one of the things
that strikes you when I read it is how
like dense it is and and so how did you
put this thing together
we stopped sleeping for about 10 months
really those are staff of about 15 1 12
15 people feeling food like the graphics
right just working around the clock I'd
say yeah just you know sacrificing
everything else in their lives if they
had anything else going for them and
the stability it completes the book it
was a big challenge for us and one that
were happy we're finally done with but
uh just a lot of hard work and the QA
how did you come up with the name the
onion
[Music]
that might be too adorable to answer
for you to give him any throws you think
there's opposing theories some sites
because of all the layers of meaning and
our stories
others say that a at the time in 1873
when the onion was invented it was the
only word that her T Herman Zwiebel knew
in English so he just named it that I
hope that answers your question
why did the Sera's is who came up with
the idea for this book how did it get
started our fearless center chief scott
Dicker's walked into the room one Monday
morning and said we are doing an atlas
and we all nodded and there's 12 months
followed I mean we would just it was his
idea from the beginning we all were
interested in doing a new book as we
have in a new book in a long time a book
of original cotton content that's right
yeah that's him yeah we haven't already
covered I guess an entire century of US
history so I guess we thought why not do
the entire world and we did it what is
your written test for what funny and
what goes in the book well we would run
I mean we had a team of chimpanzees and
we show them the material and if they
like it they press a button and if they
don't like it they hurl feces at us so
that's that's why there's so many banana
jokes India and the Alice they don't
really fit but we have to go with what
the chimp said
I'm curious what are your favorite part
to the book what do I want to crack you
up each time exam oh nothing has cracked
me up from the book in a few weeks
because I'm still trying to recover from
it but one day I think we really enjoy
the u.s. section a lot it was nice to be
able to you know hit every single state
in the nation and there is a there is
one country that is enjoyable because we
were able to take our own frustrations
about doing the Alice out on it which is
the tiny protectorate of San Marino
which is a tiny country inside of Italy
and basically we were just like oh my
goodness we have to do a whole page
about San Marino so we start like what's
our angle on it and I think our angle
was just you don't belong in an atlas
what are you doing here
yeah I believe the the history slogan is
uh here's your goddamn history [ __ ] you
we also we also have a little sidebar
about a marina a Marino you should care
about that's Dan Marino we found the
research on him a lot more industries
actually more deserving of being in that
list than D is actually his gross
domestic product we find higher than San
Marino you guys talk about how you
research the book did you research
tonight yes I think the primary source
was the BBC online CIA Factbook we used
a lot as well we also would just go and
we'd up on the history of a country just
to try to get a feel for know what's
important and unique about it and what
we should address in it so there was a
lot of painstaking research welcome back
who do you think will be your audience
who are you targeting everyone in this
church right now
you will all buy a copy of this book and
we will find it for you and make it out
to whatever name you like yes because it
is a book festival you know and we talk
a lot about writing can you talk about
how you became human writers you come
here my writers I can help start on that
one and say that when I was in high
school I was going to be a computer
programmer I was learning about quick
basic I was like boy I really just don't
want this to be my career and I think I
told my guidance counselor I was like
I'm thinking about not doing computers
and I think I want to do comedy writing
and she basically like rolled her eyes
and said let's be realistic here
and now I say look at me now mrs. Kell
oh look at me now
I don't have an answer I dropped out of
high school when I was 17 because I fell
in love with comedy and my parents were
very upset with me I did stand-up for a
couple of years and one day I found the
onion online and was totally taken away
with it and so what they were doing was
extraordinary and worked hard enough to
get on board and look at me now mrs.
Kell Oh welcome to now your rights
Gilbert has a collection of slides that
he shows when he does his talk the
slides are the ones that never his
cartoons that never made it into print
out of all the material did for the book
and the ones that the monkeys threw the
bananas at were the funniest parts that
didn't come into your book oh we had a
300 page entry on the Atlantic Ocean
which we had to cut for a room where
it's pretty amusing though here's a
here's a funny story when we when we
were doing these countries in the
beginning we were just assigning them
randomly to people and we'd sit around
in a room and before we started writing
them we'd say hey so what does anyone
know about this country let's get some
basic facts out there that the writer
can work with so I believe Dan was
assigned the African nation of Cameroon
and it was basically silent for 30
seconds and someone then said macaroon
so we had about 1,500 words on macaroon
why the [ __ ] you beautiful entry on
macaroon what is the one thing that you
would like to tell this audience today
about our dumb world in all services we
do you mentioned this at the beginning
of your presentation of our presentation
that we do feel that although this is a
humor book you will be able to take a
lot from this and actually learn a lot
while laughing and enjoying ourselves
what we definitely definitely did we
learned more about the world than we
ever wanted to know
and you can't do now so do we have any
other questions I think we might have
one right now
was the interview process you had to go
through to get your jobs difficult what
was it like and the second question did
you use to make your family's black when
you were growing up when did you know
you were funny the onion works a
different way than most places there
isn't an interview process and you don't
type up a resume
yes I think we're around of 12
interviews I'm just joking baby yeah
they just try to try to find some they
try to find people who share they're
sort of sarcastic world-weary
Sensibility
I know we've we've hired people who used
to work at sandwich shops or ice to
clean up bars until I got hired and the
candy yeah we don't we don't come you
know we never went to school for a human
right or have a fancy degree we more we
just stumbled into it that being said we
are now hiring and please send your
resumes and cover letters to editorial
at the onions at Tom we'll get back to
you in four to six weeks we actually
don't remember your second question I
was about to well my parents aren't
funny so I never made them well but it
was their fault my I guess my brother
always made my family last way more than
I did and he still does and yeah my
parents are disappointed in me
we have another question jokes about
war-torn destitute corners of the world
how how'd you work those I mean how that
comes out crosses well there was never
any situation we were scared of
addressing we just you know took care
and we're concerned about what our
target was and whether we felt our
target was there and deserved to be mom
it's not so much that the material is
how we how we presented it and so when
we made jokes about Africa many of them
come at the expense of the colonizers
and the bloodthirsty dictators and just
the terrible circumstance right that
these people have and it really is they
really have been screwed over many times
and we try to target the people who are
at fault and not the people who are
victims of right let's let me use the
humor to you know express what's going
on and there and expose it for what it
is and so we don't shy away from those
kind of situations I think that's
probably it is for con we can get you
out on time please help me thank in in
my
[Music]